starwars the rise of Skywalker has
proven to be a bit divisive among fans
but in an alternate universe they were
divided by a totally different movie
George Lucas had his own plans for the
sequel trilogy before selling Lucasfilm
to Disney in 2012 and it's safe to say
that his conclusion of a Skywalker saga
would have borne little resemblance to
the film we got a key piece of
information we have concerning Lucas's
vision for the ninth episode of the main
Star Wars series comes from Mark Hamill
Luke Skywalker himself in an interview
the star gave to IGN in March 2018
now that rise of Skywalker's been
unleashed on the world there is new
context for his remarks and it's
interesting to take stock of how the
creator's plans shifted due to the
involvement of new creatives and
unforeseen circumstances specifically
Hamill noted that while Lucas had indeed
planned to kill off Luke he didn't
intend to do so until the end of episode
9 you recall that Luke essentially
sacrificed himself at the conclusion of
Star Wars the last Jedi in order to
allow the besieged remains of the
resistance to escape the first-order
onslaught on crate in Lucas's version of
the sequel trilogy though Luke would
have had another order of business to
attend to in the next film training his
sister Leia in the ways of the Jedi in
his talk with IGN Hamill lamented that
this narrative thread was quote never
played upon in the last Jedi even though
that film the only one of the sequel
flicks to be co-written and directed by
Rian Johnson rather than JJ Abrams was
reportedly more in line with Lucas's
vision for the trilogy of course it goes
without saying that Fisher's death in
2016 resulted in Leia's role in the last
Jedi and the rise of Skywalker being
greatly diminished although given
Lucas's affinity for CGI it doesn't
necessarily follow that this would have
been the case had it remained in charge
it's pretty easy to pinpoint some of the
other major ways in which Lucas's sequel
trilogy would have differed from the one
we got for one thing they would have
centered on completely different
characters as rape Oh Ben and kylo Ren
were not his creations yes Lucas did
intend to bring back Luke Leia and Han
Solo but in regard to rise of Skywalker
in particular there's one returning
character from that film that would not
have made the cuts in Lucas's version
this would be in McDermott's Emperor
Palpatine whose controversial return was
Abraham's idea and whose comeback McTeer
med recently admitted to being
blindsided by for a simple reason
speaking with digital spy the actor
revealed that Lucas had no further plans
for the character at least not in terms
of the films in universe chronology
after his apparent demise during the
climax of Star Wars returning to Jedi
mcdermid said I thought I was dead
I thought Palpatine was dead because
when we did return to the Jedi and I was
thrown down that chute to galactic hell
yeah I'm not George said I said oh does
he come back and he said no he's dead
mcdermid went on to say that he had
accepted his character's fate up until
the prequels in a sense he wasn't dead
because we went back to the visit him
visit him when he was a young man but I
was totally surprised by this we can
also glean from Lucas's own remarks that
while the iconic principal characters
from the original trilogy would have
played a major role in his version of
the trilogy the focus of the plot would
have been slightly more esoteric than
Disney's in 2018 a quote from the
companion book to the AMC docu-series
James Cameron's story of science fiction
made the rounds online and it revealed
that Lucas had at one point been
prepared to take the story in directions
nobody could have foreseen the director
explained the sequel films were going to
get into a microbiotic world there's
this world of creatures that operate
differently than we do I call them the
Wills and the Wills are the ones who
actually control the universe they feed
off the force if I had held on to the
company I could have done it given many
observers gripes that the Disney sequel
trilogy suffered from a lack of overall
cohesive vision Lucas's version may even
have proven to be more satisfying for
the franchise as fans check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you
[Music]